le gouvernement qui est donc connu à
trois semaines du premier tour des
élections législatives le premier tour
est fixé au 12 juin prochain bixente
mayence insisté ban est toujours avec
moi en plateau puisque jusqu'au scrutin
tv 60,18 vous aide à y voir plus clair
dans les enjeux dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines avec vous
bixente focus celui-là sur la 6e
circonscription la cinq places 6e
circonscription des yvelines on parlait
de la cinquième il ya un instant mais là
c'est bien la sixième on peut commencer
peut-être par la situer exactement donc
la sixième circonscription des yvelines
située au nord du département comprend
les villes de saint germain et le pecq
hr pour que marie marelli chambourcy
aigremont ce fut la circonscription de
michel péricard le père de l'actuel
premier magistrat de saint germain en
laye puis pendant trois mandats de son
suppléant est maire de chambourcy pierre
morange une circonscription donc ancré à
droite ce qui n'empêchera pas la défaite
de pierre morange en 2010 est balayé par
la vague macro nist et par la candidate
en marche natalia kuzyutina telia plus
directe qui est candidate à sa propre
succession oui et rappelons qu'elle est
ingénieur qu'elle a travaillé dans le
groupe thales puis chez airbus et en
cinq ans les choses ont changé elle
pourra bénéficier d'un soutien qui pèse
lourd celui d' arnaud péricard actuel
maire de saint germain en laye qui a
rejoint emmanuel macron et le mouvement
horizon d'edouard philippe il tient un
célèbre avocat dans la course oui l air
a en effet choisi un nouveau venu en
politique l'avocat thibault de montbrial
il a plaidé dans des affaires célèbres
c'est lui par exemple qui représentait
les intérêts de nafissatou diallo en
france dans l'affairé strauss kahn il
est intervenu dans la sphère renault
pour défendre des salariés accusés à
tort d'espionnage industriel il a plaidé
pour la faire classe trim il est aussi
connu pour avoir défendu de nombreux
policiers les d'ailleurs favorable à
l'élargissement de la notion de légitime
défense très proche de valérie pécresse
il l'a soutenu lors de la campagne
présidentielle prenant notamment à son
compte les mesures qu'elle défende est
en matière de sécurité et qui sont les
autres candidats la candidate de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
solidaire nuque c'est une enseignante
melinda et melinda sauge et de la france
insoumise autre parti le rassemblement
national qui est relativement faible
dans cette circonscription notamment
certaines villes comme saint germain en
laye marine le pen est arrivée derrière
valérie pécresse et eric zemmour
toutefois le rain sera défendu par une
femme maria macedo desousa enfin
d'autres candidats sont déclarés pour
pour ne pas les énumérer cécile
perraudin pour la lutte ouvrière
stéphane boucher pour reconquête
jean-luc sauzée suffisait pour le parti
animalistes julien envers illac pour le
parti pirate et stéphane richard
nouvelle union écologique et sociale les
ege les élections législatives seraient
des ronds se dérouleront donc les 12 et
19 juin prochains voilà pour les enjeux
sur cette sixième circonscription des
yvelines si vous nous rejoignez où on
parlait de ces enjeux et et tout au long
de cette campagne jusqu'au premier tour
mais mains de ce premier tour des
élections législatives je vous disais tv
70,2 va vous aider à y voir plus clair
autour des enjeux de ce scrutin